(dramatic music)
- [Narrator] If you have
benign prostatic hyperplasia
or BPH, your prostate gland is enlarged.
The prostate is a
walnut-sized gland in men.
Just beneath your bladder,
your prostate gland
surrounds your urethra,
the tube through which urine
and semen exit your body.
Your seminal vesicles
and prostate make fluid
that combines with sperm
cells to create semen.
During normal urination,
urine flows from your bladder
through the part of your
urethra inside your prostate,
then through the rest of your
urethra to leave your body.
For unknown reasons,
your prostate gland may
enlarge as you get older.
If you have benign prostatic hyperplasia,
your prostate may grow
large enough to narrow
or block the part of your
urethra that runs through it.
As a result, your
enlarged prostate may slow
or block the urine flow out
of your body when you urinate.
The symptoms of benign
prostatic hyperplasia include
frequent urination or urge to
urinate, especially at night,
a weak or interrupted urine stream,
and straining to urinate.
Over time, untreated benign
prostatic hyperplasia
may cause the following
complications: inability to urinate,
damage to your bladder and
kidneys, bladder infections,
bladder stones, and urine
leakage, called incontinence.
If you have benign prostatic hyperplasia
with mild or no symptoms,
your doctor may recommend
watchful waiting,
which includes getting your
prostate checked every year
to make sure your symptoms or
health are not getting worse.
If you have moderate
symptoms that bother you,
your doctor may recommend medication,
such as alpha-blockers.
Alpha-blockers relax muscle tissue
in the neck of your
bladder and in the urethra
to improve your urine flow.
5 alpha reductase inhibitors
may also improve urine flow
over several months by reducing
the size of your prostate.
You may receive a combination therapy
of both types of drugs.
If medication isn't
relieving your symptoms,
your doctor may recommend
a surgical procedure
called transurethral resection
of the prostate or TURP.
During this procedure,
your surgeon will insert an
instrument called a cystoscope
through your urethra
to reach your prostate.
Then a wire tool called a
resectoscope will be inserted
through the cystoscope
to shave off tissue,
which will widen your urethra.
Other minimally invasive variations
on this type of procedure use lasers,
microwaves, radio waves,
or electrical energy
from tools inserted through the cystoscope
to remove some or all
of your prostate gland.
If your prostate is very large,
your doctor may recommend an
open prostatectomy procedure.
In open prostatectomy,
your surgeon will make an
incision in your lower abdomen.
After exposing your prostate,
your surgeon will make an
incision in its outer capsule.
Next, the tissue inside your
prostate will be removed,
and the capsule incision
will be closed with sutures.
Finally, your skin incision will be closed
with sutures or staples.
You can't prevent benign
prosthetic hyperplasia,
but the following lifestyle changes
can make your symptoms less severe.
Avoid medication that can make
it harder for you to urinate,
such as antihistamines and decongestants.
Stop drinking fluids for a
few hours before bedtime.
Avoid drinking alcohol or
fluids that contain caffeine.
Try to empty your bladder
by double voiding.
To double void, urinate,
wait a few minutes,
and then try to urinate again.